that movie nobody nobody yeah
it surprises me that you like action i i
didn't know you would even
get into that mostly i make fun of
action movies in my career in comedy i
mean david cross and i once
did a whole night where we showed steven
seagal movie and made fun of it the
whole night on mike's by the way i was
there when he hosted snl one of the most
famous
nightmare
like can't re-show that show ever as you
were leaving the last time i got to
interview you yeah i i said oh geez i
forgot to ask you about steven seagal
and when you pitched him a sketch that
you had written and you said howard will
save that for the next time well it's
hans in france
right and we were talking to him about i
was helping with hans and franz that
week
yeah i didn't usually help with that
piece but i love those guys and uh and
and seagal read it and he said
if i do this sketch if
i do it
and the you know they they want to fight
him hey it would take you on
he goes if i do it
i have to beat them up
like he has to it's like a john wayne
thing right like that's right like he's
got to win the most ludicrous scenario
you don't worry no one will think that
they actually no one's thinking anyone
beat anyone up here but uh that was his
attitude the whole week was
he kept saying
i've never seen your show i don't know
what you do here
like really you've never seen saturday
night live where do you live
the fight and he wrote a scene howard
howard he he wrote a scene and it's the
last scene in the show and it's like one
of his movies but they tried to do it
live they got some stunt men to come in
it was it's insane
so there's like this board of directors
there's a bunch of stuntmen in suits so
as a as a viewer you're like who are
these actors they're not in the cast and
they're and then there's like some
speech and then he enters the banquet
room and starts beating it's live and
he's beating them up
and throwing them around the room and it
goes on for like eight minutes it's the
longest scene you've ever seen and then
at the very end
he turns to camera and says this is what
happens when you pollute the planets
and the audience is mystified
just like in the movie it probably
baffles you to this day
that like why did lauren allow that the
producer of saturday night live why did
he allow this guy to hijack the show and
take over for eight minutes the show is
bigger than steven seagal he didn't need
steven seagal yeah but you know what i
mean by the time you get to wednesday
what are you gonna do but it would be
funny if he booted him on a thursday and
just did a show without it